notre invité ce soir c'est vous ap ir de
jean bonsoir à vous êtes vice-président
de l'institut atemi spécialiste de
géopolitique et vous êtes notamment
ancien colonel des troupes d'infanterie
de marine merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de france 24 les lignes de
front on a la pression vous m'arrêtez si
je me trompe appear de jongh qu'elle
n'avance plus qu'elle ne bouge plus
qu'on est entré dans une phase d'
enlisement d'un côté comme de l'autre
alors peut-être pas d'enlisement parce
que le modem qui peu exagéré mais je
pense une phase de répit c'est vers une
guerre c'est comme un combat de boxe
là ça fait six mois que les délais deux
combattants ben on va dire semaines des
combats extrêmement difficile vous avez
évoqué le nombre de morts le bal manque
le compo considérer qu'avec les civils
les ukrainiens et russes et en gros deux
cent mille morts et blessés donc c'est
absolument énorme les pertes aux
matériels sont considérables donc je
pense très sincèrement que d'un côté
comme de l'autre alors plus les russes
que les ukrainiens ont besoin d'un répit
et c'est pour ça que les poutine a
décrété une espèce de pause
opérationnelle qui lui permet depuis
deux mois en fait de mener une espèce de
deux guerres de harcèlement avec des
missiles principalement sur les sujets
sur kharkiv est ce lui permet en fait de
stabiliser le front est de créer une
espèce de petit fixation de france qui
reproduit le modèle qu'il a mis en place
en 2014 il ya besoin d'une pause
aujourd'hui ce qu'il est avec l'hiver
arrivant il est nécessaire de l'avoir et
là aussi qu'il n'a pas encore atteint
les objectifs affichés au tout début de
set cette invasion en ukraine est ce
qu'il faut comprendre que moscou ira
jusqu'au bout de ses objectifs même
passé cet hiver
alors le volet le problème c'est que
c'est psychologique et militaires
politiques écologiques mons et que les
russes n'abandonnerons jamais et qui
fera que les ibères avec tours une
solution c'est qu'en fait ils vont
bloquer sur leurs objectifs point de vue
militaire aujourd'hui les ukrainiens
sont extrêmement favorisée par l'apport
d'armement de munitions etc qui vient de
l'otan et les états unis principalement
vous avez évoqué la somme de 750
millions $ c'est considérable plus les
formateurs plus etc on voit bien que les
ukrainiens aujourd'hui on équilibrer le
rapport de force grâce aux matériels
américains se débattent des matières et
de très très grande qualité l'exemple de
lits mars un lance-roquette mons mais
c'est selon fait des dégâts extrêmement
important dans les rangs lice
aujourd'hui cible et il ya la
psychologie ou la gare on veut on veut
on veut et puis à la réalité du terrain
qui fait qu'on va finir par discuter on
voit bien qu'on vous dit il ya deux
canaux de négociations qui sont ouverts
le premier c'est sur le blé le deuxième
c'est sur les affaires nucléaires à
savoir hidjab et qu'avec eux avec la
hoya donc on voit demander qu'il ya deux
il ya deux canaux de discussion c'est
parce que comment ça pourra se
développer moi en tout cas il ya un
endroit quelque part il ya un endroit où
en fait des ukrainiens pâle avec des
russes avec des turcs évidemment mais il
n'ya pas avec les turcs et les turcs
avec les ukrainiens mais son cas est ce
qu'on peut imaginer à un moment donné
qu'on arrivera une confrontation
discussions directes entre le président
céline ce qu'ils président poutine est
ce que ça c'est envisageable à ce stade
du conflit alors elle se tape bien
évidemment que non puisque on voit qu'il
ya des motifs d'agacement un exemple
suivi la décision de faire juger le bain
le reliquat du bataillon azoff à mario
paul besset pas que la turquie voulait
calmer le jeu
série 2 de fait qui font qu'aujourd'hui
il n'est pas question mais tant que le
cette petite lumière existent de la
négociation potentiel vous dire que je
pense que sincèrement que la communauté
internationale va et veiller à ce que ni
l'une ni l'un ni l'autre des
belligérants s'ils voulaient se mettre à
souffler sur la bougie qu'il est rallumé
pire de gens de défendre un territoire
ce n'est pas forcément le reconquérir
lorsque l'on entend le président
français pour ne citer que lui promettre
que le soutien restera intact et qu'il
s'inscrira dans la durée comment est ce
qu'on arrive à convaincre les opinions
publiques de suivre lorsque l'on voit le
coût de cette guerre et les effets
qu'elle a sur la planète toute entière
d'abord on voit bien que le coût de
cette guerre est portée principalement
par les américains principalement pas le
parent le par le lucre et d'elle-même et
puis par l'union européenne or
aujourd'hui s'ils voulaient quelque part
la france se retranche en termes de
financement derrière l'union européenne
le problème c'est la cohésion parce que
le vrai sujet c'est quoi depuis
l'invasion de l'ukraine par paris il ya
le premier avant première à pâques c'est
que c'est la première fois en 1945 une
puissance nucléaire aussi vous les
menaces et de missiles nucléaires
l'ensemble de l'europe donc ça c'est
quoi ton incroyable et la deuxième fois
de le deuxième impact c'est l'autre
intensité telle que vous l'évoquez dans
votre dans votre présentation et c'est
là que c'est un vrai sujet et ça c'est
un sujet qui fait que ça révélé une
forme de faiblesse européenne et le
président battrons s'il ne s'y trompent
pas et bien sûr il
ils poussent les européens sous les
assauts à se recentrer autour de ça
cette action une nécessité parce que
cette guerre cible et démontre à l'envi
qu'on est peut-être peut-être pas
capable de résister à une terre de ce
type la donne va falloir trouver des
solutions où on verra bien évidemment à
l'automne avec la discussion sur la loi
de programmation militaire lpm on verra
bien quel est l'impact savoir que ça va
avoir mais n'oublions pas que les
allemands ont d'ores et déjà promis
d'injecter 100 milliards d'euros sur
leurs questions de défense d'ici la fin
de l'année merci beaucoup au pire de
jean merci d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur france 24